okay so the topic of this video will be
gene mutations let's go ahead and get
started
you know before we get started here's a
few questions to ponder pause the video
give these questions some thought i'm
going to proceed
so when we talk about mutations this is
a change in genetic material so in the
picture we see that a gene is a segment
of dna with instructions to build a
protein you might know a gene as a piece
of dna with a's t cs and g's in between
and those a's t c's and g's are going to
tell
the cell how to build various proteins
now some mutations if there's an
accident if there's a change in the
genetic material some mutations have no
impact
some mutations can actually be helpful
and other mutations can be harmful
so here's a piece of dna and mutations
generally happen during the process of
dna replication during the process of
dna replication
the dna is separated in half
and then
the left side is used as a template to
build a new piece of dna as paired to
t's and c's pair to g's while that's
happening the same thing on the right
side the right side is a template to
build a new piece of dna a's paired to
t's and c's paired to gs notice how the
blinking nucleotide is a mistake a t
should not be bonded to a c every now
and then mutations happen and that's the
point of this video
so mutations tend to be caused by what
we call mutagens and these are agents in
the environment something in the
environment that can cause mutations a
great example is uv radiation from the
sun we know overexposure can lead to
mutations that can trigger skin cancer
and smoking you know for people who
smoke
that can lead to mutations that might
cause lung cancer so these are good
examples uv radiation and the the
chemicals in in cigarettes
that would be considered mutagens
so here are a bunch of dna nucleotides
in black a's and t's and c's and g's and
from left to right if i were to say
perform transcription let's make rna and
in red a's and u's and c's and g's are
matching appropriately again this is
transcription
and then if i underline the aug that's a
start codon and then every three
nucleotides or every codon
i'm going to underline every three
nucleotides and i'm going to stop at the
uga because that's a stop codon and if
you remember how translation works the
ribosome will read aug so we look on the
genetic code chart here we find aug
transfer rna will deliver methionine
then the ribosome reads the next codon
ucc transfer rna delivers serine and
then the next codon
gaa that's glutamic acid the next agc
that's serine and then the next codon
ccg that's proline and then the ribosome
would stop because it gets the stop
codon that's how it's supposed to work
but now we're going to talk about a
point mutation where there's a
substitution in a single nucleotide
an example would be a missense
point mutation
so on the bottom here i just copy and
paste it this is the exact same
information on top as is the bottom
on top however this is going to be our
normal genetic information
on the bottom we're going to have a
missent point mutation
see that right there
that in yellow
that is not supposed to be a t
nucleotide that was supposed to be an a
we're pretending a mistake happened and
a t was made
well during the process of transcription
that
that will be copied into an a
and so when the ribosome comes to this
codon if we were to find acc on the
chart
there's the chart there's acc notice
it's a different amino acid it's not
serine anymore
the trna the transfer rna would deliver
the amino acid called threonine that's
the wrong amino acid
but this is an example of how a mistake
in the dna can lead to a mistake in the
rna and then that mistake in the rna can
be carried over to a mistaken amino acid
and so this leads to a change in the
amino
acid and overall if if the the protein
is made from incorrect amino acids even
though it's only one amino acid this can
alter the shape of the overall protein
you know a great example of this you've
probably heard of sickle cell disease
hemoglobin is a protein it's made from
574
amino acids
and
unfortunately for sickle cell disease
570
amino acids are perfect but one amino
acid has been substituted and in a
missense mutation and it alters the
shape of hemoglobin protein which alters
the shape of red blood cells so a
life-threatening disorder caused by one
wrong amino acid and a protein
so another example of a point mutation
would be a silent mutation now remember
on top this is our normal genetic
information
here is the exact same copy on the
bottom but now we're going to add a
silent point mutation here it is in
yellow
that g pretend has been mistaken into an
a
or through the process of transcription
you have that yellow you now
and so when you look at the amino acid
chart
when the ribosome reads you see you you
find you see you hey look at this
you see you it's the same amino acid
it's still serine
and so there was no change in the amino
acid even though there's a mistake in
the dna even though there's a mistake in
the rna luckily the same amino acid was
still delivered as a result this does
not change the overall shape of the
protein hence the reason why it's called
a silent mutation
so this would be an example of a
harmless mutation
okay so let's talk about another type of
mutation a frameshift mutation this is
where there's an insertion or a deletion
of a nucleotide where there shouldn't be
anything at all
and so on top again is our normal
genetic information but on the bottom
i'm going to add a frameshift deletion
you see that blinking t right there
pretend there was a mistake
where that blinking t
was deleted
well if that happened when we were to do
transcription
that will that a right there still be
created during transcription and i hope
you know the answer is no
and so that a wouldn't exist anymore and
now the reason this is called a frame
shift
is because this is going to cause a
shift in the codon reading remember the
ribosome reads three nucleotides at a
time not two
and so notice what just happened the
reading shift the the reading frame the
reading frame of the ribosome shifted
so when the ribosome gets to this gcc
if we have the chart there it is gcc
that's a different amino acid it's not
serine anymore gcc trna transfer rna
would deliver alanine
and then the ribosome would come to this
codon cgu
cg you notice it's not proline anymore
transfer rna would deliver arginine
and then we come to what's supposed to
be a stop codon but it's not a stop
codon anymore find gac there it is
aspartic acid transfer rna
would mistakenly bring aspartic acid
and the ribosome would keep going
because there's no longer a stop codon
and we find cau and transfer rna would
deliver
histidine and eventually it is run out
of nucleotides and so the process would
stop
but you can see this is a much more
serious uh error because it changes the
shape of the of the protein the wrong
amino acids made from mostly wrong amino
acids and in this in this example in
this example the proteins just made from
too many
amino acids as well
and so notice what happened is that the
stop codon was lost
in other examples maybe a premature
start codon would accidentally be
created
and in other examples this one would be
a good example is that the polypeptide
is made from mostly wrong amino acids
let's do another one let's do what's
called a frameshift insertion let's
insert a nucleotide where it doesn't
belong
pretend the mistake happened and a
fourth
t
got inserted right there that's not
supposed to be there and everything else
all the nucleotides after shifted down
well during transcription
all these nucleotides would be created
and so when the ribosome gets to this
codon aag we look up aag
and we can see that's lysine
and then we get to the next codon ccc
hey a little bit of good luck here it
was supposed to be proline and it still
is
but now we come to what's supposed to be
a stop coden but it's not a stop code
any anymore find gug it's valine
transfer rna or deliver valine
and the ribosome just keeps going
because there's no longer a stop codon
we find acc it's threonine transfer rna
will deliver threonine and the ribosome
keeps going because there's no longer a
stop codon au isoleucine transfer rna
will deliver isoleucine so you can see
again the stop codon was lost and this
polypeptide is made from mostly wrong
amino acids
so let's do a little bit of review read
the blue box and try to figure out what
describes scenario a and b
and c
so for scenario a i hope you said this
is an example of a missense and a
substitution mutation for b i hope you
set an insertion and a frameshift
mutation and for c i hope you set a
deletion and a frameshift mutation
well what impact do mutations have on
offspring well it depends where is the
mutation let's talk about somatic cell
mutations remember somatic cells would
be examples of non-sex cells body cells
like blood cells muscle cells
bone cells
skin cells
nerve cells the majority of your body
falls into the somatic
somatic cell category
and so if there's a mutation in a
somatic cell well that's only going to
affect the individual
you look at this picture right here the
man in this picture has been sunburned
if this man develops skin cancer a skin
cancer mutation as a result of his
sunburn
if he has children in the future will
his children inherit the skin cancer
mutation and i hope you see the answers
no skin cancer
is a somatic cell
skin cells are somatic cells and you
don't make children using skin cells men
of course
contribute a sperm cell and women
contribute an egg cell
so in this case in a somatic cell
mutation
any mutations are not passed on to
future generations
well what about germ cell mutations now
when you hear the word germ you probably
think of like bacteria and viruses
that's not what we're talking about
a germ cell in this context are the
diploid cells that undergo meiosis to
make sperm in men and eggs in women
if these are mutated well now we might
have
an example where the mutation can be
passed on
so imagine this scenario here's an egg
cell and here comes a bunch of sperm
cells notice how the one sperm cell is
flashing and has an m inside of it
pretend that's a mutated sperm cell
well if that sperm cell
were to fertilize the egg cell then yes
that mutation could be passed on to
future generations
so throughout this video a couple times
i've brought up cancers and so cancer is
a disorder in which body cells will lose
their ability to control their growth
they're basically stuck in mitosis where
they just keep multiplying and
multiplying and multiplying
so normally a cell will receive a signal
to advance to the next stage of the cell
cycle a signal from if a cell is an
interphase it will receive a signal to
go to prophase and then at the end of
prophase it receives a signal to go to
metaphase at the end of metaphase it
receives a signal to go to anaphase and
so on
and so there's a lot of genes that are
involved in this cell cycle in
regulating when cells divide now the
analogy i like is that genes are often
like light switches when the gene is
turned on they create protein so here's
four genes a b c and d and right now
they're all in the off position
but let's say there's a mutation a
mutation in these genes might lead to
cancer let's pretend that because of a
mutation
gene b and c get turned on and these
genes might be important in
the cells multiplying so even though
they're supposed to be off they're in
the on position and this kind of
triggers them to just multiply and
multiply and multiply
and so cancer cells therefore would then
not respond to the signals that normally
control the cell's ability to grow
because the genes have been activated
when they're not supposed to be
and so cancer cells can now divide
uncontrollably and form like this gray
mass that you see in the picture called
a tumor and if the cancer cells enter
the bloodstream those cancer cells can
travel around the body and spread
so there you go a little review on
mutations uh pause the video try to
answer these questions i hope you found
this video helpful thanks for watching